as we all eat early await season two of
critically acclaimed series pose we
caught up with Billy Porter and the cast
at PaleyFest who told us why the series
is groundbreaking for the lgbtq+
community our stories are being told by
the people who lived it now you know
it's a story about family ultimately
chosen family and it really shows the
world what that looks like
you know sometimes family is a little
bit different than what we're used to
seeing you know and it's time to reveal
those differences so that under so that
people can understand that we really are
all the same and we really all want the
same thing which is ultimately love yes
it gives us acknowledgement it gives us
the idea that we belong and we are part
of society and it also helps those that
are struggling with their identity
struggling with the possibility of
transitioning or not because the climate
is really not easy for those of us that
transition Philly has been a champion
for individuality with his own red
carpet looks serving up some
headline-making style at this year's
Golden Globes and Academy Awards well
you know I'm a fashion person I've
always loved fashion I always dreamed
you know I've been in this business for
30 years me and my friends will always
joke I can't wait till I can wear a ball
gown to the Oscars I got the call and I
was like I think that was the time to do
it so you know I've been thinking of and
dreaming of these things since I was the
kid yeah a dream come true for sure
Billy's co-star and longtime friend our
Lady Jaye also spoke to us about his
fierce style
Billy's a genius I worship Billy
fifteen years ago in New York I played
the piano for Billy at Joe's Pub and so
I have always been a fan of his and to
work together in this context is amazing
and I look forward to every look that he
serves us too now if you haven't seen it
the series follows ball culture in New
York in the late 80s and as you just
heard it's not far up for Billy's own
first experience in New York I you know
I used to sing at the piano bars when I
came to New York back in the 80s and you
know it really was where I cut my teeth
as a performer you know as an artist you
know you practice your art every day
whether people are listening or not
that's what we do as artists and so it
was this place where we could really do
that and when you get to practice like
that look at what you get to become and
of course some of the most memorable
moments from the series are the
categories in which the cast compete
against one another so with season two
on the horizon what were the cast
favorite categories from season one the
what the weird one I can't remember the
name of it but the one where they were
you know they were in all that the
outfit sitting to throwback to the to
the Lower East Side you know a
performance
the absurd ball where everyone was
wearing just like the crazy-looking
makeup like the green makeup with like
the orange hair and that was my favorite
weather girl is really fun I loved
weather girl that was my favorite
category
[Applause]
that was when Blanca and I battled for
the income I was wearing the black and I
think she was wearing either do you
remember what we were wearing I know I
think I was just being a bit
self-centered yeah but I love that
because I love walking in high heels
ever since a child I loved it so when we
had that category in pumps you know mr.
Murphy was like we have to make sure you
guys are saved and I'm like I've been
doing cartwheels on these things
that we were bald just having a
fantastic time so are you excited for
the return of post what were some of
your favorite moments from the first
season who do you think would make a
great guest star on the series let me
know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe to ET Canada's
YouTube page
[Music]
you